our world is divided into two Realms the
normal one where mortal humans live is
called The Waking world but there is
another world that waits for us when we
close our eyes and sleep a place called
The dreaming realm this realm is
controlled by a god-like being the
master of dreams called lord Morpheus
his job is to regulate nightmares and
dreams of the Mortal people he has the
abilities to time travel to morph
himself into other beings and even to
manipulate others Minds in the first
scene we see his beloved Raven flapping
through the air and arriving at his
castle turns out Morpheus is in pursuit
of a rogue nightmare called the
Corinthian the Corinthian escaped the
dreaming realm and proceeded to wreak
havoc on the waking World killing many
Mortals in the process so as the king of
the dreaming realm Morpheus has to take
responsibility to capture and stop the
Corinthian shortly after he dons his
mask and leaves the dreaming realm
although Morpheus is the strongest being
in the dreaming world he is weak in the
waking World despite this Morpheus is
confident that he will get the job done
with the help of his three deadly
weapons his pouch of sand his Helm and
his Ruby at the same time in 1916
England a man named Lord Magus and a
famous magician are attempting a ritual
to capture the angel of death and force
her to revive their deceased Sons they
are accompanied by their disciples who
all respond in culty unison here in the
darkness as this goes on Lord Morpheus
approaches the Corinthian in London the
latter has just killed a man and his
Morpheus is about to finish him off
suddenly he hears the chance here in the
darkness repeating in his head the very
next second he disappears it turns out
that instead of capturing the angel of
death Mages has mistakenly trapped the
king of Dreams in his basement
nonetheless since Morpheus is a
supernatural being Magis decides to keep
him hostage and takes away his sand
patch his Ruby and his Helm leaving him
powerless on the floor and because of
his imprisonment the waking world starts
going through a terrifying situation A
disease known as the Sleepy sickness
breaks out the next morning we see that
over 1 million men women and children
never woke up from their dreams meaning
they died in their sleep that afternoon
the nightmare Corinthian tracks down
lord Mages and gives him advice on how
to keep Morpheus captive because if he
escapes he'll come for them both they'll
need to trap him inside a glass sphere
which itself is inside a binding Circle
to contain morpheus's physical
manifestation Corinthian also advises
Magis to make his guards take stimulants
to ensure they never fall asleep in
morpheus's presence because if they do
he will enter their dreams and control
them at last Corinthian tells Mages to
get rid of morpheus's Raven as she will
do whatever it takes to free him later
Mages heads to the basement where
Morpheus has been imprisoned and asks
him to return his son however the king
of Dreams remains silent and naked and
barely even moves his body to respond to
the questions the same routine continues
for for nearly a decade but Morpheus
still hasn't uttered a word during this
time Mages Second Son Alex Goes
increasingly curious about the prisoner
and even tries to help him get out
however Morpheus only remains silent
narrating to himself that he cannot give
what these humans want the wish will
only disrupt both the waking and the
dreaming worlds it is now 1926 and
morpheus's stole Investments have
created Youth and prosperity for Mages
and his followers one day Alex
approaches Morpheus and again explains
how his father would let him out if he
returned his dead son unfortunately
Mages catches his son talking to
Morpheus and punishes him for doing so
he then blackmails Alex into killing the
Raven and the boy reluctantly lures the
bird into morpheus's cage and shoots it
dead a devastated Morpheus can only
watch the horror unfold from inside of
his captivity several more years pass by
and one day Mages mistress Ethel reveals
that she is pregnant however may just
wants her to abort it saying he doesn't
want any more children enraged ethyl
runs away from the Mansion but not
before stealing morpheus's Helm Ruby and
the pouch of sand because of this Mages
starts going crazy and even offers
Morpheus freedom and the chance to get
back his stolen items from Ethel if he
grants Magis immortality wealth and
influence however Morpheus still refuses
to speak this finally breaks Magis and
he takes his frustration out on poor
Alex the two get into a scuffle that
results in Mages falling backward and
hitting his head on the floor killing
him instantly devastated Alex heads to
the Garden where he is comforted by a
worker named Paul the two talk for a
while and Paul suggests he try and
reason with Morpheus however Alex fears
that it is not a good idea because he
has already committed a sin by killing
Morpheus as Raven as a result the
imprisonment goes on for decades it has
been 104 years since Morpheus was
allured and trapped in captivity both
Paul and Alex are now old and wrinkly
but they still want to negotiate with
Morpheus and one day Everything Changes
inside the room as Paul Wheels Alex away
in his wheelchair he purposefully breaks
the Enchanted Circle allowing the king
of dreams to finally use his powers
after the two leave Morpheus manipulates
one of the guards into falling asleep
and enters his dreams he then forces the
guard to shoot his gun and break the
glass sphere as soon as Morpheus gets
out he takes revenge on Alex by putting
him into an eternal sleep where he is
stuck moving from one nightmare to the
next in this way after More Than A
Century of captivity Morpheus finally
returns to his dreaming realm but to his
dismay it is not the same one he laughed
the once beautiful buildings that
existed are now dilapidated in Grim
Morpheus reunites with the realm's chief
librarian Lucian and learns that most of
the residents have left due to a lack of
leadership hearing all of this he is
devastated but nonetheless he vows to
rebuild his realm back to its glorious
image on the other hand the nightmare
Corinthian is seen in an apartment with
his latest victim he knows that his
creator Morpheus has escaped captivity
and is going to come for for him soon
then we are shown why Corinthian
actually wears sunglasses in the sockets
where his eyes should be he has a rows
of teeth like tiny mouths he is known
for his trademark of killing people by
cutting out their eyes back in the
dreaming realm Morpheus explains to
Lucian that he is nothing without his
weapons his pouch helmet Ruby thus if he
wants to rebuild his realm he has to
find them first following this we are
taken to Buffalo New York where an older
Ethel is hiding out from society she
appears to be an international criminal
living multiple lives one day she is
greeted by Corinthian who proposes a
partnership between them as they are
both enemies of Morpheus Ethel
immediately agrees and thus they begin
their Alliance when they are planning on
how to tackle the situation Ethel tries
to lie that she does not know where
morpheus's weapons are but Corinthian
brings up her son and proves he knows
more than she initially thought back in
his Palace Morpheus explains that the
only way to get back his weapons is by
summoning the trio of goddesses known as
the fates but for this he needs
something powerful from which he can
absorb power hence Morpheus visits two
dream Brothers wanting to take back a
gift he gave them a long time ago it
turns out the gift is an adorable
dinosaur named Gregory which the
brothers love very much they are
reluctant to let him go but Gregory
himself agrees to sacrifice himself for
the sake of his creator with this
Morpheus drops to his knees and absorbs
the creature's Soul now he has enough
power to contact the fates following
this he transports himself into the
dreams of others a land which he did not
create there Morpheus finds a mysterious
snake with the help of which he finally
summons the fates the three goddesses
take the snake from Morpheus and in
return provide him with a clue about
each item The Leather Pouch filled with
sand was sold in London last purchased
by a magic user called Johanna
Constantine the helm was traded away to
a demon from hell in exchange for an
amulet of protection and the Ruby was
gifted from a mother to his son that
Ruby clue was not very good back in
Buffalo Ethel still continues to say
that she is unaware of where morpheus's
tools are but in reality she traded the
sand and Helm for a fresh start in the
U.S while her son John took the Ruby
from her when he got older this means
that the Ruby can be still one with an
eternity of life in response to her lies
Corinthian prepares to cut her eyes out
but before he can proceed Ethel reveals
that she doesn't need morpheus's weapons
as she has her own she then brings out
the Amulet of protection that evaporates
Corinthian Into Thin Air instantly after
this Ethel goes to a prison-like
hospital where she meets with her son
John who is now an old man she inquires
about his therapy and tries to converse
but Jon doesn't say anything elsewhere
in the dreaming realm Morpheus informs
Lucian that he must go to London and
find his pouch of sand so that he will
be strong enough to travel to hell for
his Helm and just after he leaves
Corinthian is thrown to the dreaming
realm as a result of Ethel's mysterious
amulet Lucian greets him and attempts to
convince him to stay out of the waking
World however Corinthian is adamant on
returning there in the next scene
Morpheus arrives in London and meets the
magic user who supposedly has the pouch
Johanna Constantine he tells her that
they have business to handle however she
shrugs him off and leaves saying that
she has an exorcism to deal with then
she goes into a church where she learns
that a rich princess is trying to marry
a footballer expectedly Johanna is
confused as to why the couple would
require an exorcism but just then she
hears the princess screaming it turns
out the football player has been
possessed and soon a demon climbs out of
his mouth it completely eviscerates the
football player and turns its attention
on Johanna Morpheus also arrives at the
same time and recognizes the demon the
two then begin conversing but
Constantine takes advantage of the
distraction and exercises the demon back
to Hell following the incident
Constantine and Morpheus finally have a
proper conversation outside where he
asks about his pouch of sand but to his
dismay Johanna reveals that she couldn't
open the drawstring so she sold it
Morpheus insists they must find the
pouch because his realm will cease to
exist otherwise if dreams disappear
destruction will follow however Johanna
does not pay heed to what he is saying
and walks away after the two-part waste
Morpheus notices a raven that has been
sent by Lucian to assist him the bird
introduces himself as Matthew and vows
to protect Morpheus at any cost next we
see Morpheus arriving in johanna's
dreams she appears to be having a
nightmare where a demon is trying to
drag her to hell just then she wakes up
and finds Morpheus in her room he
explains the detractor through a dream
and wants to help her since Constantine
experiences nightmares almost every
night Morpheus promises to get rid of
them this finally convinces her and she
begins looking for the sand pouch as she
looks in her office Morpheus finds
pictures of Johanna with her girlfriend
Rachel this triggers something in
Johanna and she realizes that the sand
pouch is actually at her girlfriend's
place in the next scene the two head to
Rachel's house to retrieve the pouch
Johanna explains that she used to live
there not long ago however when all the
people close to her started dying one
after another she decided to leave
Rachel to keep her safe soon the two
enter the house and are taken aback to
find Rachel under the spell of the sand
pouch her condition is so fragile that
she cannot even speak turns out she has
become addicted to the sand and the
dreams that come from it causing her
body to wither away as Morpheus
retrieves the sand patch from Rachel he
explains it wasn't meant for humans he
then prepares to leave but Constantine
demands he help her ex-girlfriend since
it was his sand that ruined her Morpheus
degrees and asks her to wait outside he
then pours sand over Rachel and puts her
out of her suffering it allows her to
have one last peaceful dream of Johanna
before she passes away back in Buffalo
Ethel reveals to her son that she only
stole the magical weapons because she
thought they'd help when Mages men came
after them she hid the Ruby and traded
the others for the mysterious amulet of
protection around her neck it has kept
her alive all these years but now she
doesn't want to continue any longer
hence she wants to return the Ruby to
Morpheus in hopes that he'll forgive
them however Jon wonders if they should
give it away when they could use it to
dream of a world without the king of
Dreams himself in reply Athol reveals
that many people have already died for
the Ruby and it's not worth keeping she
then takes off her Amulet of protection
and gives it to Jon as a peace offering
Ethel explains that it kept her alive
for 116 years so it should keep him
alive forever with the amulet now gone
her body begins to age rapidly and she
dies in John's arms leaving him
devastated hearing screams a guard
arrives and Witnesses the corpse he
quickly assumes that Jon has murdered
her and fires a bullet at him but
surprisingly because of the Amulet of
protection the bullet bounces back and
kills the guard instead after this Jon
walks out of the building which has been
keeping him captive for years as he
stands in the cold Buffalo streets the
Corinthian appears from behind and lends
him a coat Jon who thinks the man is
simply a stranger says that he doesn't
want it but Corinthian insists the final
scene shows Morpheus informing Johanna
of her ex-girlfriend's peaceful passing
in her sleep he also reassures her that
she won't be experiencing any Nightmares
From now on after she leaves Morpheus
and his new Raven friend Matthew discuss
their next move to go to hell this show
kicks ass be sure to catch the following
episodes on series Recaps